you just turned 40 years old and look at
this picture last week this came out the
day that you turned 40 years old that's
right tell them tell them we've grown
and sexy what's that tell yes you told
that bodies like this like penny is
saying that's exactly that's exactly
what my torso looks like there's no
difference between how you look and how
I look yeah that's pretty incredible are
you were you worried about turning 40 oh
yeah you know it started out ruh you
know it was real cool cuz I was playing
up in the South Pole phone with Jake and
I was playing a promoter and manager so
I was supposed to be like like cuddly I
was supposed to be nice and soft like
you were not supposed to because he's
the fighter right you're there you're
the manager slash promoter yours not
supposed to be the one who's incredibly
cut chiseled oh yeah so you know I was
having pizza and cookies enjoying myself
I was like yeah you did right you did
good Jake make him look good by
comparison yeah all right well I have to
say you look absolutely what you do on
your birthday you do have a party yeah I
traveled oh I went through from orbit in
New York to Miami I was in live keo days
if you have places I really enjoyed
myself you know because I had to prepare
myself underwear campaign free go so I
almost got that spot yeah we're gonna
said they went a different way and now I
find out at you hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please